[Music]
hi everyone i'm len may i'm the ceo and
co-founder of endocannahealth and i'm
here to ask
and even possibly answer a question
are precision therapeutics here
well before i do that let me kind of
establish something
the
medical
cannabis program is the main reason why
we actually have legal or decriminalized
cannabis not only in the us and north
america but also you know in
a lot of places throughout the world
but if you take a look to see and this
is a slide about canada but north
america in general is found the same
trend as we start seeing more and more
[Music]
adult use or recreational use states
come on
we're seeing the spending kind of
exponentially grow towards non-medical
cannabis away from the therapeutic and
i'm going to try to interchange the word
medical and therapeutic and the reason
for that is because the fda recognizes
medical as you know going through
double-blind placebo studies so i'm
going to try to use that
interchangeably with therapeutic but
basically having the same sort of uh
the same thought around that
nomenclature so you can see that the
spending exponentially has grown but if
we really dig through the numbers a
little bit more and we actually asked
ourselves are these really strictly
medical or the non-medical conditions
if you look at the surveys that have
been done you have you know to help
relax and feel more confident to help
sleep to relieve
feeling of anxiety anxiousness
are these therapeutic are these medical
are these non-medical we're these are
questions that we're asking well
i want to dig a little bit deeper
because in digging a little bit deeper
i can see that
there are 71 percent of the responders
to a study that talked about
you know looking at replacing
over-the-counter medications uh using
phytocannabinoids
uh also
looking at how this impacts your life
and if you look at this other uh you
know slide you can see that there's
motivation for friendships or better
social engagement or mental health
improving home life and marriage
the question is medical still
therapeutic non-medical
at the very least
i would say therapeutic and if you see
there's a fun fact that people americans
are spending more money on cannabis and
they aren't pizza which should give you
an indication of how much money is
really being spent on cannabis at least
what's being accounted for i'm sure it's
a lot more with the grain black markets
once again
still trying to establish the fact of
this whole nomenclature and this uh
feeling of medical versus non-medical
uh if you see the top categories of
where people are spending money they're
spending money on edibles
and out of all the edibles gummies
now
to establish this fact again and we're
talking about precision therapeutics
right so
we understand you know my daughter
consumes her vitamin d or vitamin c in a
gummy so you have multivitamins in
gummies now when you have isolated
molecules in a gummy it makes
sense uh whatever the bioavailability
may be but if you have the constituents
of
phytocannabinoids you have cannabinoids
you have terpenes you have uh you know
flavonoids all these different things
that are presented to you that's really
not the absolute best uh modality to
consume because you know most of the
most of the edibles and especially the
gummy products have an isolated molecule
like thc or cbd or two isolated
molecules it's a distillate and an
isolate of cbd and thc that are combined
together but it's not giving you the
full constituents of the plant and in no
way are they actually uh aligned
for precision therapeutics so these are
all the things that we're looking to
address based on the pressures of
governments based on where the money
flow is going and based on what's
available uh to the actual consumer
so if i'm going through and i'm looking
at a little bit deeper on what's
available to the consumer and what are
people using for so we have you know for
instance epidiolex right so epidiox is
approved as the only of the approved uh
cannabinoids phytocannabinoid substance
and uh you know out of the responders to
this survey 14 are using for seizures
but if you kind of look down you see
where people are focusing their efforts
they're focusing on
pain and inflammation something to
address
their condition of feeling of pain or
inflammation or discomfort mental health
feeling better about themselves and
their mental health as well as
sleep sleep has been a huge one so once
again the question is is it
medicinal
is it
non-medical is it therapeutic
the it's a very very difficult thing to
do to find a truly therapeutic precision
therapeutic
phytocannabinoid formulation for an
individual that truly needs it even for
those specific conditions as you go into
a dispensary
it's all over the place and being able
to look at specifically starting with
somebody's uh predispositions to things
and then guiding them to something
that's more specific to them and then
having a feedback loop to be able to
account for efficacy that's really
precision therapeutics so the question
still exists let's see
now
going forward
the question is how
can we transform lives improve access to
medicinal or therapeutic cannabis and
advanced patient outcome i love this
quote by voltaire i've used in
many many presentations but the art of
medicine consists in amusing the patient
while nature cures the disease
nature we've already known this for
hundreds of years
yes there's placebo but we have these
substances in nature and you think about
this way a lot of the pharmaceutical
drugs that are being created came from
substances in nature and the way that we
consume these substances even drugs they
actually bind to receptors and release
endogenous neurochemicals so you know
that's what we're really looking for to
see what we can do to get some of that
nature nature's healing power
without creating an adverse event for an
individual so we can help address those
symptomatic conditions and eventually
you know address the disease that may be
the root cause of those
so this is really
what i want to establish and the reason
why
we are at the intersection where
precision medicine really meets digital
health
it became accelerated a lot more
through coven
we have become much more comfortable
having a conversation with our
healthcare provider the same way we're
having a conversation now
online to resume or through another uh
type of medium to be able to have a
conversation with a healthcare
professional
now the other thing is through covet we
feel that maybe the healthcare system
wasn't prepared maybe there was some
failures there so looking at this in a
positive way we have been empowered a
lot more
to be able to have a collaborative
experience with our health care
professional
what i mean by that is
we know a lot more about what's going on
with some of our health care needs and
we can have a much more educated
conversation with uh the provider or our
physician to be able to say how can we
join forces together so we so we can
both work on addressing my
immediate health care concerns now years
ago you go to a doctor tells you take
two of these call me in the morning you
don't really question those things
now
we're questioning a lot more and getting
more in depth about understanding our
own
predispositions to health so once again
the intersection where precision
medicine meets digital health
and where phytocannabinoids and also
other therapeutics are aligned with your
dna
your dna is
a starting point that is your blueprint
to understand what your predispositions
are and then also including biometrics
and other biomarkers what that leads to
is hyper personalization
and hyper personalization not only means
better outcomes but one of the keys are
to help minimize adverse events
when we met with the fda they said
what's the purpose of your test i didn't
talk about what we do yet but just to
know what we communicate was to help
people avoid an adverse event and they
were really supportive of that
from that we go into
what we call biocommerce and biocommerce
means personalized products products are
created specifically for the individual
or a category of individuals basically
people that are similar in that way so
maybe an archetype and that creates a
truly personalized experience so still
continuing uh trying to answer that
question about precision therapeutics
now if we go into the definition of what
is precision therapeutics what is
precision medicine the emerging approach
for disease treatment and prevention
that takes into account individual
variability in their genes
their environment
their lifestyle
and for each individual person and we
have our endo dna test to be able to do
that now i'm going to go into a little
more detail on that but just to you
understand that we have a test that we
created that allows us to right now
sequence about 675 000 different uh
snips single nucleotide polymorphisms
that are directly or indirectly
associated with your endocannabinoid
system it's hipaa and gdpr compliant and
the way that you would use that is a um
a buccal swab where you swab this in
your mouth you were registered and then
you would mail the sample back to our
lab
another way is if you have raw data from
the 23 me your ancestry any other dna
test you can upload that data to my dna
live which i'll show you and you'll get
your report instantaneously and i'll go
into that a little more detail on how it
works but just to kind of establish
what it is that we're talking about is
so right now we have our endodna test
and as i mentioned before that looks at
a person's endocannabinoid system
and all the related pathways so directly
or indirectly we're focusing on specific
genetic traits that are associated with
not only your uh your endogenous
endocannabinoid system but also
phytocannabinoid use and as i said to
help prevent adverse effects or mitigate
the adverse effects
the other thing is
uh pharmacogenomics and pharmacokinetics
so the first thing is pharmacogenomics
what we look at is drug to drug
interaction now
i had covered so i was taking 14
different supplements now the question
is how do those supplements themselves
interact together some of them are
inducers some of them are inhibitors and
how they interact with phytocannabinoids
these are all interesting questions to
ask and that's really the overview of
how
these things work together so we have to
guide people into that experience of
interaction
the second thing is pharmacokinetics and
that talks about dosing now we're always
taught about you know milligram per
kilogram etc but if somebody's 250
pounds and somebody's 125 pounds but one
of them is a rapid metabolizer while the
other person's a poor metabolizer well
guess what the poor metabolizer can
consume let's say an edible first pass
uh slower onset you have an 11-oxy
hydroxide conversion slower onset much
more powerful onset
experience with their phytocannabinoid
use due to that conversion
but in addition to that if they have
predispositions to stress reactivity or
uh you know slow rate of fear extinction
and other anxiety-causing uh
predispositions now also uh things like
psychosis or psychomatic effects
somebody can be in for pretty intense
experience and that's what we want to
mitigate and the third
test that we just found a patent for is
our neurodna test now that has two
separate sides to that the first one
looks at treatment-resistant depression
it looks at things like uh
like
different binding affinity to pathways
serotonin gaba dopamine but on the flip
side of that
we're also looking at different
psychotropic therapies like psilocytin
ketamine lsd
mdma ibogaine etc and then seeing what
the optimal therapeutic is for the
individual
looking at possible adverse events that
may be associated with that uh treatment
protocol as well as their genetic
predispositions so truly looking at a
more precise way
to be able to deliver a psychotropic
therapeutic
so just to give everyone a little bit of
an overview of how
how end of dna works the test the first
thing you would do is you would log into
your secure anonymized portal which is a
software called mydna live on there you
would have your dna results you would
have your health profile which gives us
a baseline from there
you we have your
drug to drug interaction
and all those build your personalized
wellness plans now if you can take a
look at this i know it's kind of small
but you can see that every single report
gives you the the definition of the
symptomatic condition
also gives you a summary of findings in
the summary talks about
that this person may be prone to
higher rate of stress reactivity which
can actually cause an anxiety event
now this is really important and on the
science side we're looking at a gene or
a single nucleotide polymorphism it's
called pha fatty acid amide hydrolase
that produces an enzyme
that breaks down an andamite really
really important note and i'll mention
this in a second you can also see that
the report gives you your genotype your
gene it gives you uh your rsad it
actually is supported by pvu reference
every single report that we have has to
have a peer review reference we build a
machine learning algorithm also
that looks at
different
studies
pulls them in based on certain criteria
and then we have a science board that
goes over those make sure that the right
ones are being added in addition to that
we're also involved in a bunch of
different studies in clinical studies
and i'll share that in a little bit more
but this is a really interesting gene
because it has a lot to do
and we're conducting the study right now
with the roof finding a pattern between
the expression of that gene and also
people that are talking about uh pain
and discomfort and inflammation and it
makes sense because if you have a
stressful event all these neurochemicals
are pumped into your bloodstream you
have
dopamine you have adrenaline you have
norepinephrine you have cortisol and you
know after some time when your brain
realizes no line chase in the jungle
there's a reuptake of those
neurochemicals now
one of the other things that happens
there's a release of secretion of
anandamide which is our endogenous
endocannabinoid and when that happens
you're also
you're then getting back to homeostasis
which is the goal of the endocannabinoid
system balance but if you are breaking
down your anandamide faster than the
average person you're really not
producing enough now that cortisol level
stays longer can reduce your ph level
make you more acidic you can have an
overactive immune response which you'll
feel as pain inflammation and then it
can actually go into your gut health and
create your gut health issues if you're
predisposed to that so there's
definitely a correlation between those
and that's what we're finding out in our
studies now just to continue on really
uh quickly uh we also have a dosing
part which looks at metabolic function
as i mentioned what type of metabolizer
you are of certain uh cannabinoids thc
cbd or them together we're also looking
at drug interaction so we have over 200
prescription medications they're looking
at those specific drugs and seeing how
they interact
and then from there it creates your
personalized wellness plan with the
major indications of why people consume
cannabis and all the way down to product
matching the way product matching works
is we use certificates of analysis and
we go through an algorithm to help match
the percentage of that uh products
cannabinoids terpenes etc to what your
suggested ratio is and also geofence to
see how how close that product is or
where you can find it closest to
you where you reside
now we also have a physician view the
physician view is fully integrated into
the electronic health record system in
the electronic health record system you
can order the test just you would of any
other test uh like blood work urine etc
and then it's fully integrated so you
can print this pdf you can make notes
and all that is found on one screen
now
that's where we are today where we're
going tomorrow is full genome sequencing
whole genome so when we do whole genome
what that means is it's personalized
therapeutics everything you're looking
at personalized nutrients personalized
vitamins skin anything else it's truly a
personalized therapeutic and it's a huge
game changer for us to be able to do
that in addition to doing whole genome
sequencing we're looking at polygenic
risk scores and apologetic risk scores
are basically validated assays of
hundreds of thousands of people they'll
look at thousands of genetic markers and
we're able to
create a predisposition allocation so
people that have this genetic
predisposition are more likely to
experience c-reactive protein levels
that are higher related to inflammation
also major depressive disorder also
different diseases and different
conditions so as we move forward that's
another biomarker to create
a more personalized therapeutic approach
the next part of that is how do we
utilize that in real world uh
applications so sleep lab it's one of
the studies that we're doing right now
and that's one of the things we're
implementing so one of the ways that
we're going to be using this or are
using this in daily life is an
individual would fill out a health
profile
they would speak to their care account
so their care counselor would make sure
they created the proper um
overview and completed their health
profile correctly and see if they have a
specific issue that they want to talk to
a healthcare professional a prescriber
about the healthcare professional will
then order specific labs including the
dna test
once they get the results they review
the results and they provide them a
personalized protocol the pro
nice personalized protocol is
accompanied by a biometric device which
we call the endo link device as you see
here and i wear that every day you also
have an app that allows us to see
frictionless feedback one of the major
challenges with patient reporter outcome
is when somebody starts feeling better
they actually
they actually stop responding to patient
reporter outcome but to be able to
voluntarily and be identified in the
identified way to be able to get your
biometric data frictionlessly allows us
to really understand the efficacy of the
protocol that's being suggested
so what you would see
behind the scenes is
we're not just measuring think of it as
sort of a ring and a fitbit in one so
we're looking at all these different
biometrics and you're engaging with that
so not you're empowered to see what's
going on how's this protocol working in
my sleep not only am i sleeping better
longer but what is the quality sleep
what is my heart rate variability etc
but also in the insights you can see how
you can compare to general population
and in which percentile you fit based on
those biometrics but the interesting
part about it is behind the scenes what
we're getting is we're getting genotype
and phenotype information
we're also getting ppg data which is
important because it gives us raw ppg
data to be able to analyze so heart rate
rate variability oxygen levels we can
either measure uh you know snoring
capacity arterial elasticity etc and
also through remote monitoring all that
information is then goes into our
machine learning
and the machine learning algorithms can
create
better predictive inferences so it's
truly an end-to-end solution where
there's oversight and we can modify the
protocol based on that information that
comes through
it's really important because we use a
lot of that in our clinical
and observational studies so these are
some of the ones that we're involved
with some of them have been completed
and published and i'll share those with
you but some of them are ongoing studies
like the cannabinoid hyperemesis
syndrome which is done anxiety
chronic pain etc
so just to give you an indication of one
of the studies that we have published
recently along with credo sciences which
is uh you know dr ethan russo as well
we're looking at cannabinoid hyperemesis
syndrome and one of the things we're
able to find that in our cohort
uh over 70 percent of participants
versus the controls had four different
genotypes in common
which is a
a pretty significant ratio and number to
have a predictive inferences inference
related to cannabis hyperemesis syndrome
which definitely people
are are suffering from so we have to be
able to understand the root cause of
that and then being able to create a
protocol that you know is more um
more specific and precise whether it is
you know abstaining from cannabis but
understanding the root cause of that and
perhaps an interaction that is also
involved so you can read that study on
pubmed
now the other study that we're involved
with is with stacy gruber's team at
harvard medical associate with mclean
hospital and that is focusing on a
sublingual delivery of cannabidiol cbd
for anxiety and remember i talked about
fob fatty acid amide hydrolase well
there's also akt1
cnr1 there's a whole bunch of genes that
are associated with the increased level
of anxiety and
when we see that certain people or cbd
you know working as an agonist
that is more efficacious but other
people
it's less applications so as soon as we
start kind of creating those archetypes
of people based near genotypes based on
our biomarkers we are getting a lot more
precise and that's really the goal the
goal is to get that precision
therapeutics
going forward not only
with anecdotal data but real world data
that we can measure
now
that is what we do and this is our goal
and our goal is to have the world's
largest observational study so the
thousands and thousands of people that
are coming to us and i want to really
really emphasize this because people are
concerned about data and their personal
data yes we're collecting data data is
really important but len may's personal
data is not important it's thousands of
people that have
a genetic uh certain genetic variants
that have taken a certain protocol and
have reported patient pro patient
reported outcomes that are efficacious
that is the true goal of creating the
world's largest observational study now
we're still involved in clinical studies
and it's really important but i want to
emphasize that these are de-identified
they have a number not a name associated
with them and it's really important to
know that uh just for the geeks out
there that want to know what technology
we use uh we're in amazon's aws we're
hipaa compliant gdpr compliant so that
information resides on a different
bucket in aws your personal information
along with your genetic information and
it's encrypted so you can have that
information come back
decrypt that and read the results for
you and
healthcare professionals doctors
whoever's
you know participate in this this is
truly an important tool because we
really align with
not only getting precision therapeutics
but really looking at avoiding those
possible adverse experiences so just to
kind of introduce you to some of the
team members uh just so you know who's
behind all this me some of the other
people that are part of endocanna health
you know from athletes to people who
have worked in corporate and really
looking at our scientists our scientific
advisory board is spectacular we don't
have everybody on the slide but just so
everyone can understand and see that we
are
not just putting names and not just
putting uh people's titles on a slide we
meet at very least once a month with the
entire advisory board the scientific
advisory board we talk about specific
subjects we help each other with studies
and we participate in each other's
studies and there is a tremendous value
of having some of the world's best
scientific and medical minds participate
with us because that really truly
creates credibility in what we're doing
and
finally
i'm answering the question i hope i
answered the question for each and every
one of you
that precision therapeutics are here and
i was able to support
that question with all the data that was
able to share with you and hopefully uh
all those questions will be answered and
if not uh reach out and i'll be happy to
answer those questions myself personally
and with that i want to thank each and
every one of you for listening for
providing me your attention i know
everybody is busy and my email is on the
slide so feel free to reach out with any
questions and i'm truly grateful for the
opportunity thank you so much
you